aux côtés des soldats de l'Armée de
l'Air ukrainienne tout un symbole se
sont eux qui assurent la sécurité
aérienne du pays et eux aussi qui sont à
l'origine des attaques de drones sur la
Russie
la Russie a tellement peur des
défenseurs de nos cieux qu'elle a
déclenché des frappes de missiles
démonstrative un jour avant vos vacances
ces derniers jours les attaques
aériennes se multiplient dimanche qui
est avisé deux ponts atchenard et Nichet
deux lieux stratégiques les
infrastructures relient une région
occupée par la Russie à la Crimée
annexée par Moscou en 2014 selon les
autorités russes les explosions auraient
détruit un terminal privant de gaz 20
000 foyers dans la région les
terroristes de Quié font tiré des
missiles Storm Shadows sur le pont de
chunard et le village de tionar le pont
a été endommagé par une fusée Moscou
s'attaque à des bases militaires de
l'ouest de l'Ukraine l'un des missiles a
déclenché un vaste incendie non loin de
là dans un entrepôt de maïs des frappes
en guise de représailles selon Kiev
alors que les attaques de drone visent
en Moscou et plus largement le
territoire russe se multiplient